.
Jeder kennt einen Soziopathen.
Vielleicht bist du
mit einem Soziopathen befreundet,
vielleicht sogar mit einem zusammen?
Freunde der Sonne, das hier ist
ein recht spontanes "Reaction-Video"
auf Shane Dawsons aktuelle Serie.
Kann sein,
dass euch Shane Dawson nichts sagt,
weil er ein
amerikanischer YouTuber ist.
Aber im englischsprachigen Raum
zählt er zu den größten YouTubern,
würde ich sagen.
Er ist derzeit bekannt für
mehrteilige YouTube-Doku-Serien.
Er porträtiert gerne kontroverse
YouTube-Persönlichkeiten.
Sein Ziel dabei ist es,
mal 'ne andere Seite
von diesen Menschen zu zeigen.
Die Kehrseite der Medaille,
die man als Zuschauer normalerweise
bei YouTube nicht sieht.
Seine aktuelle 8-teilige Serie
dreht sich um Jake Paul.
Wem das nix sagt, Jake Paul ist
der jüngere Bruder von Logan Paul.
Bei Logan Paul sollte es
bei den meisten klingeln.
Das ist der Typ
mit dem "Suicide-Forrest-Skandal".
Shanes Serie
dreht sich um die Frage,
ob Jake Paul ein Soziopath ist.
In Folge 2, die inzwischen
17 Millionen Menschen gesehen haben,
besucht Shane eine Psychologin,
um von ihr erklärt zu bekommen,
wie man einen Soziopathen erkennt.
Das Buch, aus dem vorgelesen wird,
ist das "DSM-5".
Die aktuelle und fünfte Auflage des:
"Diagnostic and statistical
manual of mental disorders."
Im DSM-5 stehen alle anerkannten
psychischen Störungen und
Erkrankungen
und deren Klassifizierung.
Hier geht es um antisoziale
Persönlichkeitsstörungen,
auch bezeichnet
als Psychopathie, Soziopathie
oder dissoziale
Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Ich lese euch mal vor, was
die diagnostischen Kriterien sind
für eine antisoziale
Persönlichkeitsstörung laut DSM-5.
1.) Das Versagen, sich in Bezug
auf gesetzmäßiges Verhalten
gesellschaftlichen
Normen anzupassen.
Was sich im wiederholten
Begehen von Handlungen äußert,
die einen Grund
für eine Festnahme darstellen.
Zerstören fremden Eigentums,
Belästigung anderer Personen,
Diebstahl oder
Ausübung illegaler Tätigkeiten.
2.) Falschheit, die sich äußert
in wiederholtem Lügen,
dem Gebrauch von Decknamen
oder dem Betrügen anderer zum
persönlichen Vorteil oder Vergnügen.
Incentives können sein:
Geld, Sex, Macht.
3.) Impulsivität oder Versagen,
vorausschauend zu planen.
Das kann sich äußern in:
unvermitteltem Wechsel
des Arbeitsplatzes,
der Wohnung oder des Partners.
4.) Reizbarkeit und Aggressivität,
die sich in wiederholten
Schlägereien oder Überfällen äußert.
5.) Rücksichtslose Missachtung
der eigenen Sicherheit
oder der Sicherheit anderer.
Das kann sich etwa äußern
im Fahrverhalten,
also wiederholte Raserei,
Trunkenheit am Steuer,
Häufung von Autounfällen.
6.) Durchgängige
Verantwortungslosigkeit,
die sich
im wiederholten Versagen zeigt,
eine dauerhafte Tätigkeit auszuüben
oder finanziellen
Verpflichtungen nachzukommen.
7.) Fehlende Reue,
die sich in Gleichgültigkeit
oder Rationalisierung, also
Selbst-Rechtfertigung äußert,
wenn die Person andere Menschen
gekränkt, misshandelt
oder bestohlen hat.
Außerdem äußert sich so eine
antisoziale Persönlichkeitsstörung
häufig durch
das Fehlen von Empathie.
Also die Unfähigkeit, sich in
andere Menschen hinein zu versetzen,
mit seinen Mitmenschen
mitzufühlen.
So, damit hätte ich jetzt Shanes
45 Minuten langes Video abgedeckt.
Denn inhaltlich passiert nicht mehr
als das, was ich hier erzählt habe.
Die Psychologin
liest aus dem DSM-5-Buch vor.
Genau das,
was ich gerade vorgelesen hab.
Nur mit sehr viel Drama.
Falls ihr Shane
zum ersten Mal schaut,
muss man vielleicht dazu sagen,
dass dieses überzogene Drama
sein Stil ist,
den er normalerweise mit
einem gewissen Augenzwinkern
und bewusst übertrieben serviert.
Doch in Kombi
mit diesem Thema, finde ich,
hat er sich
doch irgendwie im Ton vergriffen.
Weil das für mich jetzt
nicht übertrieben humorvoll wirkt,
sondern einfach nur
traumatisch und angsteinflößend.
Nee, um es genau zu nehmen,
sind es schätzungsweise 0,2
bis 3,3 Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Sprich:
im Zweifelsfall nur einer von 500.
Beziehungsweise bis zu einer von 30.
Und ja: Wenn es einer in 30 ist,
ist es ziemlich sicher,
dass einer von uns
einen Soziopathen kennt.
Das eigentlich problematische ist,
finde ich,
dass er sich hier mit einer
Expertin zusammengesetzt hat,
die aus dem DSM-5 vorliest.
Was dem Ganzen einen sehr
wissenschaftlichen Rahmen gibt.
Aber nicht nur der Schnitt
des Videos und die Musik,
sondern auch Aussagen wie:
"da läuft's mir kalt
den Rücken runter,
ich hab da so ein schlechtes Gefühl
im Bauch mit diesen Menschen",
das sind alles natürlich
unwissenschaftliche Aussagen.
Ich kann nur ständig wiederholen:
alles psychologische
ist auch gleichzeitig biologisch.
Es gibt
ein sehr extremes Beispiel dafür.
Das ist der Fall des Phineas Gage.
Phineas Gage
war ein freundlicher, höflicher,
zuverlässiger junger Mann,
der im Jahr 1848
einen schrecklichen Unfall erlitt,
bei dem
sein vorderes Hirn durchbohrt wurde.
Erstaunlicherweise überlebte er.
Und noch
ein bisschen erstaunlicherweise
überlebte er als anderer Mensch.
Er war kognitiv... also, er war
genauso intelligent, wie vorher,
aber er war jetzt plötzlich
ein impulsives Arschloch.
Falls ihr euch z.B. für die
Neurologie dahinter interessiert,
wir haben für "SchönSchlau" eine
Reihe gemacht zur dunklen Triade
Narzissmus, Machiavellismus
und Psychopathie.
Die verlinke ich euch.
Könnt ihr euch nochmal anschauen.
Ich möchte jetzt noch 3 Sachen
ergänzen, die ich wichtig finde.
Erstens...  * DING DONG *
Moment!
Hi.
- Hach. Du bist wieder zu früh!
- Aber wir haben doch
das wichtige Announcement.
Ich weiß, aber wir machen
das immer in der End-Card.
Ich komm gleich noch mal.
Sorry.
1.) Nicht alle Soziopathen
oder Psychopathen sind "böse".
Unter Serienmördern zum Beispiel
gibt es einen ganz hohen Anteil
an Psychopathen bzw. Soziopathen.
Aber umgekehrt heißt das nicht,
dass jeder Psychopath
ein Serienmörder ist.
Ein sehr interessantes Beispiel
ist der Neurowissenschaftler
James Fallon.
Der zufälligerweise im Rahmen
seiner Arbeit rausgefunden hat,
dass er selbst
ein waschechter Psychopath ist.
Wie er im Buche steht.
Er hatte die entsprechende
Hirn-Physiologie,
er hatte entsprechende Risiko-Gene.
Und er gab auch selbst zu,
im Alltag manchmal so ein
bisschen arschig unterwegs zu sein.
Er selbst meint, dass es auch
ganz viel mit der besonderen Liebe
und Zuneigung zu tun hat,
die er als Kind genossen hat.
Damit komme ich direkt zu 2.)
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
Psychopathie und Soziopathie?
Im DSM-5 wird
kein Unterschied gemacht.
Und Psychologen
sind sich auch nicht ganz einig.
Manche sagen, man sollte oder
kann das gar nicht unterscheiden.
Andere benutzen
ganz bewusst "Psychopathie",
wenn sie auf genetischen Ursprung
hinweisen möchten
und "Soziopathie", wenn sie
auf erlernten Ursprung hinweisen.
Z.B. wenn es ein Trauma gab
in der Kindheit
oder eine frühe Misshandlung,
die dazu geführt hat.
Jetzt weiß man aber,
dass Gene und Umwelt
eigentlich nicht zu trennen sind.
Alles, was mit Psychologie
und Verhalten zu tun hat,
ist sowohl genetisch-
als auch umweltbedingt.
Und zwar sehr oft sehr stark
miteinander verknüpft.
Beispiel: es gibt das "Warrior-Gen".
Das "Krieger-Gen".
Wenn ich diese Genvariation habe
und dann noch in meiner Kindheit
ein traumatisches Erlebnis erleide
oder misshandelt werde,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass
ich eine Psychopathie entwickle,
sehr hoch.
Wenn ich aber nur
dieses "Warrior-Gen" habe
oder "nur" misshandelt werde oder
traumatische Erlebnisse erleide,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit jeweils
zur Psychopathie nicht so hoch.
Nur die Kombination.
3.) Nicht alle Psychopathen
oder Soziopathen sind geniale,
manipulative Genies,
die die Welt wie ein Marionetten-
spieler unter Kontrolle haben.
Viele Betroffene
leiden unter Arbeitslosigkeit
oder haben
kein richtiges soziales Umfeld.
Es gibt natürlich auch
hochintelligente Psychopathen,
die dann besonders manipulativ
und gefährlich sind.
Aber das ist dann schon eher
das Bild, das wir aus Filmen
oder von den Medien kennen.
Shanes Video behandelt Soziopathie
ironischerweise recht unempathisch,
was ja eigentlich
das Ding von Soziopathen ist,
aber soziopathische Menschen werden
hier als unmenschlich dargestellt,
als kalte Maschine.
Damit wird ein Klischee bedient,
was Shane mit einer Reichweite
von 17 Millionen Menschen
vielleicht etwas sensibler
angehen könnte. Müsste.
Es gab auch
viel konstruktive Kritik.
Es waren wirklich
gute Kommentare unter dem Video.
Andere YouTuber
haben darauf reagiert.
Eine sehr valide Kritik ist,
dass man für eine professionelle
psychologische Diagnose
nicht einfach das "DSM-5" nehmen
und YouTube-Videos anschauen kann
und dann 'ne Diagnose abgeben kann.
Shane ist sehr gut mit der Kritik
umgegangen, hat sie ernst genommen.
Er hat sich auch
in Folge 3 dafür entschuldigt
und die nächsten Folgen
entsprechend umgeschnitten,
um das zu berücksichtigen.
Auch, wenn sich Shane
im Ton vergriffen hat,
finde ich die Diskussion gerade
im amerikanischen
und englischen YouTube
erstaunlich konstruktiv
und sehr wertvoll.
Weil ich psychische Gesundheit
auch sehr wichtig finde
und das ein Teil unserer Gesundheit
ist, der so oft übersehen wird,
dachte ich,
ich beteilige mich an der Diskussion
und bringe sie
rüber nach Deutschland.
Findet ihr, man sollte
über psychische Störungen
und Erkrankungen besser aufklären?
Gibt es eine spezielle
psychische Erkrankung oder Störung,
über die ihr gerne
mehr erfahren würdet?
Die wir bei MaiLab mal
in einem Video behandeln könnten?
Wenn ja,
schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Und jetzt kommt die Endcard:
MaiLab wurde nominiert für den
"Fast-Forward-Science-Wettbewerb".
Und es gibt einen Publikumspreis.
Wenn ihr möchtet, helft uns!
Unter diesem Video,
"Fluoride verkalken das Gehirn",
zählen bis zum 14. Oktober
jeder Like und jeder Kommentar.
Und jeder Kommentar, der eine
Diskussion anstößt, zählt doppelt.